yeah hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to blueprint
Tycoon now this is a resource management
kind of base building style game and
it's hard to describe because it's very
simplified from everything so I started
the tutorial but I'm gonna walk you guys
through it howdy
we've been given these islands and
tasked with setting up a settlement to
gather in profit from their natural
resources because whenever you come to a
new land you want to exploit absolutely
everything you can for profit as your
assistant I will guide you on your
journey to building a successful
efficient and profitable settlement
workers are the foundation of any
enterprise let's hire some by building
houses because the only way to get new
people is to build houses and they
automatically come with so you press
hard to rotate you do the thing with the
thing and the thing in the things do
like that and at that and then you got
two houses your blimps come over and
then they start construction somehow and
then you cancel bill mode and you need
to build a marketplace so the
marketplace goddammit this music is too
cheerful oh Jesus just stopped sorry
that was like I don't know what it was
but that was like destroying my brain
okay this is much better so we need to
build a marketplace to be able to
provide our workers with the appropriate
sustenance for food so with the
marketplace you want to build it I don't
know kind of close maybe I'm not
hundreds I'm sure what but you also need
to build roads to be able to get
everything going from one place to
another like this we just get our
marketplace to be able to deliver food
to the workers houses so that they can
live which is handy I suppose for
whatever you're trying to do but also
you need to provide the marketplace with
fresh food do you be able to do that so
in order to do that you need to oh I can
actually put these kind of right there
and then build a road over there now the
cool thing about this game and what
makes it really interesting is that it's
all on this blueprint grid and it
doesn't get any more detailed than this
it is basically narrowed down to just
the gameplay and only the gameplay which
is kind of neat and then when you build
your things you need to build routes
because apparently these things don't
navigate
themselves you need to coordinate
everything which I imagine means that
the game gets way more complicated as
you go down the road and it just told me
there are no routes I know I'm aware
okay so once you do that you need to
left-click get a vegetable to go over
there so you can deliver the vegetables
make the new oh I gotta follow the
tutorial I'm sorry I know what I'm doing
BAM just like that and then you can make
another one like that and then you got
your vegetables being delivered from
what I can only assume are farms to
there and then immediately the food goes
to the workers houses everything is
moving freely okay this is where I
didn't get in the tutorial so this is
new to both you and me building
materials over buildings require
materials to be built build a wood
Harvester near the construction doesn't
have to be linked to houses you got it
baby
we're gonna get wood up in this honker
so it doesn't need to be connected to
houses so that means that I can just put
them kind of in a line
maybe this is probably a bad place to
put it but okay now we need to set up a
route so we need to make the tool drag
route tool set up for work am I already
on the Oh God
huh Oh over here okay I got it
so select from building the wood
harvester to the construction okay well
that was easy
add some rows and watches goods are
harvested and ready to be delivered
you got a baby boink and just like that
we've got wood going into the
construction site build former
workhouses and remember to connect them
to the market place of the working Pina
their food you can speed up time blah
blah blah I'm an expert at this already
you don't need to worry about me ha
boink habu ski hub or ski hey bong oh ha
bonk ski there we go and knob up boo-boo
there you go now we can get some
researchers build two researchers houses
with roads connecting to the marketplace
well [ __ ] I didn't know that we're gonna
need all that okay so we need to build
researchers houses because apparently
they're better and they live in a higher
class society than simple menial workers
apparently this sounds like we need
someone to overthrow the government
already but that's besides the point
okay so I want to slot them in and just
here and they just need to connect to
the marketplace so you're kind of
getting the basic principle of
everything here you all [ __ ] oh [ __ ] how
do i how do I get rid of that Oh God
this huh thank goodness my perfect order
is not gonna be perturbed these
researchers want some apples whoa gives
us [ __ ] what the researchers want we're
trying to get by with good vegetables
how are we gonna survive on fruit ah
goddamnit bunch of needy bastards Hirai
fine we'll do it your way
sack of [ __ ] build a road going from
there and then I'll build a route I know
what I'm doing
get that to their apples get that - Gus
[ __ ] get that to there BAM so we got our
routes the apples are being delivered
and the apples will be delivered from
there to the researcher houses
then hopefully oh we build a lab okay
can do building a lab where do I do this
huh III suppose this doesn't need to be
established anywhere near anywhere else
hopefully so I could just put it right
here along the roadside and ha Bisky lab
allows us to research new tech to craft
better more valuable goods yeah so we
can sell it and make a profit because
that's the only thing that I care about
this is this affecting me I'm gonna I'm
gonna do this real quick
oink okay doesn't that look lovely click
on the lab you got a boss pic research
you got a boss tear - I don't know what
that means we require red vials to
complete this research build a red vial
crafter near the lab how many things am
I gonna craft holy [ __ ]
okay anyway oink and I guess we're gonna
put this right why does it have an input
and an output yeah I don't like the look
at that point red balls are made with
wooden stone build wooden stone
harvesters set routes up to the red vile
crafter and watch red bow crafted okay
boink and I'm assuming that I got to
connect around the back way so let's
just do that
boink and I can slot something else up
there so I need stone harvesters and I
can do that trial was just one first
boink and then we got that and do I need
do ya I need to set up routes so we need
this to go their new route and then we
need this to go their new route and then
we got wooden stone being delivered easy
peasy lemon squeeze me and everything's
good yeah all wait this one doesn't have
a route I need to get this to there yeah
okay got it now that we have some red
vials let's use them in the lab we're
doing it we're making science it's a
beautiful thing okay so we need red
vials used to the lab so we need the
whoo boink okay the lab is working let's
wait for research to finish you can
speed up time with the bottom of the top
bar all right look at that and this is
just the beginning of this game I saw a
trailer for this game
the ending was just a sprawling Sh
mortgage borg of an island filled with
nothing but crafting and researching and
a whole bunch of cool stuff going on so
there's a lot of potential in this game
i just don't know how to do it yet are
we doing it how do I know oh we did it
tier 2 unlocked I don't know what that
means tier 2 building materials in this
case iron ingots oh god how do I know
how to build that build a coal Harvester
next to the iron harvester and set up a
route to deliver coal to the storage ok
I don't have get coal whoa Oh calm down
there whoa getting all jiggly with it I
put that there
woah oh I didn't even see that colonize
I'm gonna do that I didn't even know I
had this over here oh that's for making
Mons okay then we need iron ore we need
whoa no fertility here
no fertility why do I need why do I need
people banging butts to be able to get
iron on the ground there's a joke in
there about something getting hard but
I'm not I'm not having none of that that
is that is horrible
okay but I can do that cuz apparently
there's fertility up there and I I
ruined my chances of having more iron
okay build a core harvester set up a
route to deliver to the storage can do
oh yeah I can do that okay route storage
iron ore okay route storage coal got it
okay so that should be good Cosima
now we have the base materials for
crafting iron ingots build an iron ingot
crafter good god it's endless amounts of
craft ivities yeah okay so that means oh
[ __ ] I shouldn't have built it so dense
in here it's getting problematic um I
don't know if people would be able to go
through one
to get to another building that makes
sense right people could cut through the
market and they'd be able to get where
they need to go right question mark so
if I build this here and then I build
this here and this here then we have
something going on and I can set up a
route from the storage to the earning it
crafter Bank
okay that's good right I hope so the
better be good cuz if it's not good
whoa oh I didn't even see that well what
is going on in there why doesn't that
look like crying childs from five nights
at freddys Oh God
Oh what have I done what is happening oh
god that's so weird oh so cool I don't
know what's going on by thinking whoa
prettiest waist which needs to be
properly disposed of come on there's so
many requirements how's anyone supposed
to keep track of all this [ __ ] okay
waste disposal set up around from the
ironing and crafter to the waste
disposal well okay waste disposal [ __ ]
man what the hell all right we're gonna
do this like this because I may have
made an error so we got that now that
can go there and then the waste disposal
be there set up a route hot abiding hot
about Alma go the waster there all right
then now set up a route to deliver iron
ingots to construction oh god damnit why
is that gotta be so how's it gonna be so
much okay oink
ooh be doodoo yeah alright so we got
that who are doing great I think who
knows really all right great job the
iron ingot supply chain is fully
functional you've learned how to hire
workers and fulfill their needs set up
routes research new tech and new goods
types while disposing of waste next
we'll learn how to create our own
blueprints to maximize efficiency click
Next to continue to the next scenario
good god in this scenario we learned how
to make our own highly efficient
blueprints right let's try to gather or
and craft into gold ingots and then we
can look
what built a gold or Harvester in the
highlighted selection oh my god okay how
about I tuck it into the corner that
seems a more efficient I don't know man
I don't know uh yeah hi rescission
contradict our blueprint go to new
blueprint what what is this oh is this
what was going on in the middle of the
box holy [ __ ] oh man
okay goal is to gather the goods and
drop them in the output you can drag
windows around by holding the left mouse
button on the window tile okay on the
right side you can see the blueprint map
and on the left side you can see the
workers and tools you have available
this is a blueprint we're gonna make the
workers will grab the goods grab them
move them to the output and drop them
first we need to equip the worker and
the harvester so we can use gather
action okay
workers move one square at a time so
let's change the starting position on
the lower left a better place oh my
goodness Oh grab so we want to grab that
Oh gather sorry gather item will be
spawned in that location selector grab
action so this worker grabs the item
when it's spawned grab output drop oh oh
no oh no oh my brain is gonna explode oh
my god do I have to do that for all the
buildings Oh God
I didn't want this much micromanagement
man this is gonna take me forever to
properly learned learn digit
okay so we put this here let's rotate it
like this so we got an input and an
output
okay so select the gold new blueprint Oh
God Oh what am I looking at this is a
crafter blueprint you have inputs welds
craft outputs and final output the goal
is to grab the goods from the inputs
drop them in the welds and use a worker
to
weld them together when all the goods
about is the crafted approvals bond
would be tested oh my god
what the Frick holy poop huh on the boob
room we have two available workers on
the welder and card tools we'll have
green worker grab the goods and position
on the welds the blue worker will weld
them together and carry the crafted gold
and get to the output you equip the card
on the green worker the card allows the
worker to carry up to three Goods okay
three goods it's like the start position
start select the surfaces and grab grab
grab so we got three of them because we
got the cart I get that move to the
first goal drop move drop move drop so
we grabbed three we dropped three now we
need to set up the welder so the blue
worker
there's a green worker in the blue
worker so we need to set up the welder
start that from here we need to weld
left weld down to weld it into one ingot
and then grab the final product that
will be made once you weld those
together and then drop it in the output
section oh I got it save the blueprint
Wow
your workers are currently idle because
the building is none of the input
materials set up a workaround from the
gold harvester to the ingot crafter well
I got a set up the road first jeezum x'
man these guys do not make it easy for
me so I'm going to do for now just do
that huh oh whoa woof woof but you can
see the thing that I did that's what we
were looking at before into that square
is exactly every step that I made so not
only are we building on a macro scale
out here on this island not only are we
doing that but also deep down inside it
there's an even smaller grid we're
crafting is being done so you can see
how the simplicity of this is masked by
the sheer complexity of its intricacies
of its inner workings of its inner
machinations so Wow
holy crap time to make some money okay
this is gonna be finally the reward for
all this [ __ ]
workers need to be paid or they will
become unhappy yeah
or starve to death you know one of the
other okay contracts right now the only
contract available is in stone contract
which pays 101 per item grab the stone
contract okay fifteen goods per day
seldom stone by building a stone officer
with the worker out to the delivery
storage you got it so stone harvester
and delivery storage I can do that
easy peasy stone Harvester we'll build
it right he ano and then we need to road
it up road it up and then we can make
routes point and then boink
okay so we got stone going there but do
we have oh we're on the same place that
we were before Oh handy that it made it
exactly the way I made it huh cool okay
sell some stone okay so speed up time by
building the harvester wait what has no
oh we need to make a blueprint in it
default blueprint okay the blueprints
already there we just need to make it
okay got it got it got it okay so now
it's being done I forgot that it
actually needed a blueprint but the one
in here is not too complicated cuz it
was just gather and then deposit so Oh
congratulations you just made some money
cool all right
but it seems like our money is
decreasing I don't like the sound of
that there's more profitable contract
now available for gold ingots gold
ingots are already being crafted and
sent to the port we need some way of
moving them to the delivery storage
that's where airships come in airships
transport large quantities of goods in
between storages reports our ships are
built in your main building selected now
this is the main building where you can
build airships trading ships and tokens
click the airship button to queue up a
construction you got it baby
will do the default blueprint boink I
don't want to set up a new blueprint for
that that would take too long and hi my
brain would explode halfway through my
brain has exploded like three times
already but we're getting there we're
getting there okay next wait for the
airship to finish construction whenever
it's done doing that remember you can
speed up time Hubbell and bam okay so
it's done the airship is built now let's
build a trading route to support airship
activate new route we're taking gold
from the port and setting it to delivery
storage and we need to pick gold ingots
as our thing so if that was complicated
we just picked the airship and we
created a new route inside of the
airship from the port to delivery
storage and we had to select that so now
it's done and now it's gonna go open the
contract windows which is down here
select gold bada-bing can deliver 15
goods per day gold pays better so tried
to deliver all of that so we're gonna
decrease stone increase gold I guess we
can just max out gold but I don't know
how many gold we can produce when I
guess 10 all right that'll do
boink top right you can see current
active nice if not enough goods are
present the delivery storage workers
will become idle I would hope they they
were default to stone as well if you
have idle workers you will see a message
the amount of missed income due to not
having enough goods balance your
contract amounts to maximize profits to
ensure okay so you do have to balance it
all right we already researched tier 2
we can upgrade our building scrap some
green tokens in the main building you're
gonna baby main green I don't know what
these are
let's see what that ah can't even do
that okay got it
we're building whatever the hell green
tokens are they look like green bitcoins
but I don't know if that's gonna help us
point all right the gold ingot crafter
is not producing as much as it could
because it does not have enough gold or
upgrading the gold orc harvester to
increase the speed of the blueprint okay
you got it gold ore harvester slow down
time a little bit upgrade wait no we
don't have enough green oh there we go
why wasn't it there before I thought I
already made that but apparently not see
alright great now the harvester more
workers will predictable televizzle blah
gold Arvid Harvard Nevada brood over the
Bobbitt ah okay upgrade the worker route
select the gold over for her servicer
upgrade the work at her out how do I do
that
Oh
ad worker yeah is that what I wanted I
think so what oh my god oh here okay
that was confusing dear to worker outs
move faster and carry up to two Goods at
once look at that a new mission has been
added to the contracts missions or
special limited contracts that must be
fulfilled mission is asking us to supply
20 microchips I don't know how to do
that topper and sand but there's no
fertility on the island oh we get to
colonize okay so that I had to wrap my
head around it real quick but we're
gonna colonize it we got a port when you
colonize your first down you get a free
ship which is awfully nice thank you for
that Island has great fertility for
copper and sands which are two goods
that need to craft microchips okay I
have a feeling we're gonna need more
airships aren't we
I'll just build two and have them ready
okay build a copper Harvester in a sand
Harvester you got it baby
oh that's very fertile I don't like
saying that not enough workers
ah [ __ ] do we got to build them over
here I'm not building them over there
[ __ ] that I'm building them over here
where I don't have to worry about [ __ ]
all right how long huh Boeing and how
going why not find out another up here
ha boink okay have a day huh have it uh
hope okay we got more workers and
hopefully they're gonna cross the sea
and actually go where I need them but
who knows they might be lazy okay we got
that okay and we can need copper oh it
overlapped I'm gonna destroy that one
okay we're just gonna do - we're gonna
do two two's good enough for me get
these to the port
boink okay all right then we need
crafters for microchips so I guess we
can put them right here can't we makes
sense right
this goes here this goes here this goes
here this goes here they all go there
and then the road connects back to the
other side okay now you have all the
necessary stuff so we need to do default
blueprint cuz I'm not doing that default
I guess when you put a default blueprint
it just applies it to everything across
the ball
and so hopefully when that happens it'll
be done maybe I can upgrade these yes I
can upgrade nice so I suppose I could
just keep building these which would be
nice okay microchips are being did you
send them to delivery Stewart and
khalipa fleet the mission okay so
delivery storage over there
[ __ ] so go there and then port to port
ah come on use a ship to transport a new
route from there to there give me
microchips and then boink okay hurry up
u-boat bastard
we got microchips to deliver and then we
can do this from here to there no goods
oughta feel possible open to new okay we
just got to do this manually then and
then microchips over there and
everything is hunky-dory on the island
we're doing great work all the workers
are doing what they need to do to work
we got upgrades across the board we're
building lots of coinage we need more
wood but I'm not worried about that
that's like a later problem to have we
do have a lot of waste so but now I'm
not worried about that either [ __ ] we
need to take care of the trash problem
[ __ ] okay so I need a dude this one's
route edit route to also bring the waste
over there we go okay got it
BAM microchips so new route huh Bosque
so that's doing that let me get this
other one doing it as well cuz that
would be handy-dandy bada boom bada boom
bada boom boo boo boo bang baby oh the
transports can carry all of them I
didn't know that well if I'd have known
that I wouldn't have done that so much
all right move faster baby we got stuff
to do you hopefully we can that's pretty
much it I don't know what we're gonna do
with all the garbage but I need someone
to do the we only need one of these at a
route let's see clear route go from port
to goods airships and [ __ ] move move
trash here move trash here that's good I
don't know
it's good enough fine so long as
microchips are delivered here which we
got a whole bunch of them so hopefully
we can change this out and go more
microchip route okay everything's good
alright everything's cool modify the
contract amounts we're doing that we've
got five of eleven microchips but we
need actually we need ten more I think
we're good
no [ __ ] why don't we have so many stuck
in there alright screw everything else
we're going all microchips all my
money's on the chip of micro yeah we did
it cool nice that concludes your
training yeah that was just a tutorial
holy [ __ ] I'm not ready okay no uh I'm
bailing I quit I'm done save this okay
done holy [ __ ] I feel like I just
learned another language in about 30
minutes my god my brain is filled with
information I hope your frontal lobes
are throbbing with intelligence at the
moment but either way that is blueprint
Tycoon I forget how much it is but it's
on Steam it's not too expensive there's
a lot of depth to this game so this is
your style of game this is right up your
alley because it's about as complex as
it gets and micro managerial as you
could possibly want so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye mr. clown man okay
oh that's a mean joke